You may have asked yourself at some
point using Git 'how do I undo that last
commit?' We've talked about how a
commit has a commit ID and that it's
really important because of the metadata
that includes. Now let's talk about some
ways that you can undo commits and
especially which ways are the safest. My
best suggestion for changing a commit
in any way is to use 'git revert'. Now, when
you revert you're not technically
undoing the commit you're actually
creating a new commit with the exact
opposite changes of whichever commit
you'd like to undo. This means the
commit ID remains unchanged so it's
absolutely safe to do even on commits
that you already pushed to the remote
repository. There's other ways that you
can undo commits too, but you need to be a
little bit more careful about how you do
them and if you're actually using these
commands on public commits, commits that are on the remote repository. 'git reset'
is a very popular way to do it and in a
lot of use cases is the best way. Now,
maybe not so much to undo history but to
change the words that you use in a
commit message is 'commit --amend'. 'git
cherry-pick' doesn't so much
undo a commit but it's important to know
that it does actually change that
commit ID. So, to recap: if you want to
undo a commit 'git revert' is the best way
to go there are other options, but always
be cognizant if you're changing a
committee ID if that commit is on the
remote repository.